j'aime bien l'expression de mon neveu
quand il était tout petit quand on lui
demandait que fait ton oncle Ben disait
que c'est chef du village
Jérôme Sourisseau je suis né à Cognac en
Charente de formation je suis agrégé de
physique-chimie et je suis devenu chef
d'établissement scolaire puis engager en
politique alors d'abord comme militant
puisque j'ai commencé à adhérer au CDS
quand j'avais 18-19 ans je suis toujours
resté fidèle à cette famille jusqu'au
modem aujourd'hui je suis maire de
Bourg-Charente qui est une commune d'un
peu moins de 1000 habitants qui
quasiment à toucher la ville de Cognac
et président l'agglomération de Cancun
même à l'époque je me suis engagé à
l'UDF plus particulièrement puisque
c'était un rassemblement de famille au
centre des démocrates sociaux je me suis
rendu à ces universités d'été à cenios
et là j'ai rencontré beaucoup de
militants on a beaucoup échangé sur le
fond et ça correspondait complètement à
mes valeurs et je me suis engagé à ce
moment là et je n'ai jamais quitté cette
famille la France sa tradition c'est de
faire marier l'ensemble et d'emporter
tout le monde d'aller loin d'être
exigeant de laisser des libertés mais
aussi de tendre la main celui qui est le
plus en difficulté écrit sur le bord de
la route je trouve que cette famille
politique
incarne beaucoup de choses mais
notamment ça c'était une des choses qui
m'a vraiment attiré quand j'avais 18 ans
il se trouve que pour les élections de
2008 l'ancien maire qui était assez âgé
avait décidé de ne pas se représenter
donc très rapidement j'ai constitué une
liste et donc du coup j'ai été élu en
2008 j'aime bien l'expression de mon
neveu quand il était tout petit quand on
lui demandait que fait ton oncle malgré
ses chefs du village j'aime bien cette
expression parce que c'est pas le chef
au sens autoritaire mais j'ai jouécu
dans cette commune donc je connais tout
le monde je connais toutes les familles
j'ai accompagné tout le monde pour les
bons moments de la vie les mauvais on
connaît chaque recoin voilà on est une
référence on a un repère et on
accompagne tout le monde dans la grande
discrétion ceux qui sont vraiment en
difficulté que ceux qui réussissent
c'est extrêmement diversifié donc c'est
un mandat passionnant exigeant mais
c'est un mandat passionnant